au chili cette fois les travaux de
forage vont débuter pour tenter
d'extraire les 33 mineurs coincés depuis
presque un mois à 700 mètres sous terre
leur attente sera longue au moins trois
mois certains commencent déjà à craquer
et pour les aider à supporter cet
enfermement les secours multiplient les
échanges avec leurs familles lionel
feierstein elle était attendue comme le
messie
la strata 950 cet énorme foreuse de 30
tonnes devrait dans quelques heures
commencé à creuser le trou de dégagement
quinze à vingt mètres par jour peut-être
plus en attendant à 700 mètres de
profondeur
les 33 mineurs chiliens bloqués essaye
de garder le moral
j'envoie une pensé à ma femme que
j'adore à toute ma famille à mes cousins
maison que qui nous attendent on essaye
de s'organiser les charmes aux collègues
à sa nourriture ici qu'il n'a pas encore
manger là vous voyez on a des boissons
énergisantes
au moins on est tous bien hydratée c'est
ce qu'on voulait hier pour la première
fois les proches des mineurs on tue le
droit de communiquer directement avec
eux une minute par famille je suis
contente je suis très contente de
l'avoir entendue comment va-t-il
il va bien il est en forme l'année
dernière
selon les autorités les cinq mineurs qui
souffrait de problèmes de dépression
semble aller mieux tout le groupe a
déménagé dans un endroit plus sec de la
mine côté santé des médecins ont fait
passer par ces tuyaux des vaccins
notamment contre le tétanos et la
diphtérie
hier le pape s'est adressé en espagnol
aux mineurs et aux familles souhaitant
qu'ils gardent leur sérénité
cette excellence ça nous fait beaucoup
de bien à la fois nous est vraiment de
la foi et beaucoup de patience
les autorités chiliennes ne s'attendent
pas remonter les mineurs avant deux ou
trois mois